[Music]
oh have you put your dick on that Tick
Tock filter yet where it's like
there's like a tick tock Trend where you
like put a naked picture of yourself and
let this AI filter turn it into a
painting was the filter intended for
people to like post nudes or was it just
like a no turn your picture into AI yeah
sort of deal yeah and so people are just
posting their yeah I see I have I have
so many ideas for like AI things that I
like want to make but just don't even
know where to start I don't have the
time hit it I don't even want to say
this one because I think it's a really
good idea I'll tell you what after you
should sell that to framebridge so what
is it that you think I said what what do
they think that
I said uh a cool fun way to share uh AI
art with your grandparents yes exactly
well like the the with push
notifications yes
the product that I came up with yeah
I'll tell you it right now it's a frame
it's a digital picture frame
with an email and you can email your
nudes to it no it's your AI art
and no and then it'll create air from
your nudes but then put them in a
picture frame framebridge.com for your
grandparents have you ever wanted to
send your grandma a picture of your [ __ ]
but it didn't feel right
now you can kinkily get this off in a
way where she is
we gotta make a commercial for that yeah
that's so funny do you want to send like
nudes to people without getting arrested
your grandma's smiling at a picture
frame and it's like what just like the
Oscar Meyer Weiner no there's just like
a tree in the middle of a field yeah
yeah but like vaguely yeah penis looking
yeah no not even it's just kind of
yeah a thing you know do you have any
ideas a I aren't yeah well AI in general
like you know the company Jasper it is
the fastest like private company of all
time to go from like zero dollars to
over a billion dollars in valuation it
happened within like a year and a half
and it basically it just uses AI it's
like copy dot AI ever you ever use that
or hear about it no it's for like
creative people or anyone that's writing
anything any sort of copy anything they
just ask this service hey what's
something I could write for this and it
spits back out like 10 different options
got it so we could use it for our
Instagram captions we could use it for
our podcast descriptions right we could
use it probably for talking points even
yeah so it's [ __ ] crazy and it's like
they're growing so fast because every
company in the world is like oh this is
gonna help me you know this is going to
help all my writers save like you know
50 of their time Society is over culture
is gone but I'm we could do something
what what should we do
well I'm still chewing on your idea
because it's a good idea but you know
who I think is gonna [ __ ] absolutely
steal your thunder what is Apple
what do you mean I could see them
making something like that so it's a
good idea it is yeah it [ __ ] happens
to make it it is a good idea so let's
make it first and then I guess yeah no
what I was trying to do is reassure you
that like if you don't pursue it don't
feel bad because I think the race is
extremely intense right now to do all
these things okay but don't you think
that this is kind of exactly like the
beginning of the App Store where
everyone was making millions of dollars
on fart apps yeah because they're like
oh this is what happened at the
beginning of the web it's the first
person that got the first guy to make
fart.com made probably millions of
dollars and so they were like oh let's
just do this so like there has to be so
many like bare minimum just scratch the
surface like low-hanging fruit ideas
that we could just do yeah or someone
could I mean I don't know any like AI
Engineers so it'd be hard for me to do
it but maybe we can just hire one at TMG
then TMG can invest in it well I was
kind of thinking today like what's a
podcast specific use case for this I
don't know talking points
um yeah yeah uh talking points
captioning Auto notating things you talk
about so like someone doesn't manually
have to do that that exists
um already which is kind of cool we
should maybe start doing that and like
Auto transcription
for like our YouTube descriptions or
something or like our model captioning I
guess I meant like instead of a person
manually manually manually including
links and stuff to things yeah there's
like some just super intuitive [ __ ] that
as you're speaking
like that would be crazy as [ __ ] if you
could integrate that in an editor like
Premiere yeah and it's just Auto like it
just like scans the audio and then it is
already piping in clips and stuff into
your project file like you don't even
really do the edit I know that's
definitely gonna happen too I feel like
yeah
or you know downloading your friends
that's like a not super feasible but
also not super unique one but
just imagining a [ __ ] AI engine where
you just like give it some detail and
then you go into a metaverse type
experience and then it's just populates
a room with friends like based on your
personality and it's just like fully
coherent Ai and you're just like they're
like exactly the same as you yeah it's
basically her but it's you having your
own podcast yeah yeah I love that that's
what AI is going to do it's going to
eliminate podcasts and give everyone
their own yeah yeah where you can
actually be a part of it yeah there has
to be something for podcasting that we
could do oh what if you could digitally
insert Mr Beast into every episode yes
okay that's now we're talking if there
is an AI engine to let you have any
guests that would [ __ ] the game up
that's how you flatten the competition
right there no podcast has a unique
guest yeah that's what we need to get
into the business of we need to create
the bots of podcasting
that ruin podcasting
it'd be really funny actually if we had
someone sitting there right there right
there that was like an NPC yeah that is
like anytime we said anything they were
like here's the clip you're looking for
here's one that oh [ __ ] we're gonna have
to mute this one
marketing agencies and companies
worldwide will go ape [ __ ] for this you
know how much money this will save them
oh my [ __ ] dude but I'm the worst person
on Earth what is it
you automate community community
interactions so if you have an AI like
log into your Twitter your Tech talk
whatever and that's the thing doing all
the comments and responding to people
and it has to has to exist I mean does
it it has to be what half of them are
already yeah if you guys you know if you
guys thought that that's actually our
staff commenting on stuff on TMG Studios
nah this is a computer yeah oh oh [ __ ]
we could automate our bosses here uh
executive producer's job
yeah yeah okay let's build an AI engine
to replace Ryan yeah I think that's a
[ __ ]
Zeus chaperone when you sit there yeah
he's chaperoning just to make sure
yeah to make sure we're not touching
each other yeah what's left of human
existence is over yeah
like it's it's done
well what's sad is that like everyone
thought that like Ai and Robotics would
replace
you know like blue collar Jobs first
nope and and I mean it has for the most
part but also like the creative
all the creative fields are like getting
decimated yeah everyone was like like
nah you still need people for stuff yeah
exactly and it's like you actually don't
need people for anything that's what
it's becoming clear you know we're we're
out of here dude it's over
someone needs to build the automation
system that just takes us out I've felt
forever that
entertainment can be automated I think
that's when you talk about creative I
think that's the scary thing an engine
could literally download all the media
that we have now all the music we have
now
I feel like I could just start pumping
[ __ ] out in a way that no one can have
those jobs anymore yeah I know it's
already happening with music
uh what part I don't know I've heard a
couple people talk about AI generated
music and how it's getting like really
close to like actual pop music yeah
well dude at this point like it's
effectively building a car with people
the people are just sort of assembling
the components right but the parts
themselves are kind of stamped out I
don't know kind of by software and other
things what AI may push towards is an
absolute test of The Human Condition
which is when you
take away the wide array of our intents
and our aspirations and what gives us
value what is left yeah if we can't be
[ __ ] selfish artists and Rich
computer programmers and you take all
that [ __ ] away then why are any of us
here
and I think everyone will be extremely
depressed
this is a fun episode yeah yeah
everyone's like go back to Harry's
sucking dick this feels really bad yeah
I mean at least you could direct the
computer to make that you could that's
going to be a reality so yeah maybe even
even if it becomes
a lever pushing Society where
the on the ground stuff
is more automated you still can't Trump
like actual creativity and thinking
outside the box and stuff yeah